تسابق الولايات المتحده عقارب الساعه كي
لا تتهاوى بنوكها كاحجار الدومينو لا تريد
اداره بايدن ان تعيش الولايات المتحده
كابوس 2008 ثانيه سباق اداره بايدن مع
الزمن يذكر بسبتمبر عام 2008 عندما فشلت
السلطات الامريكيه في انقاذ بنك
مدافع البنك الى الافلاس مسببا ما وصف
بلسسونامي في الاقتصاد العالمي يطمئن
الرئيس جو بايدن الامريكيين بان نظامهم
المصرفيه امن تضع السلطات الامريكيه بنك
سيليكون فاليل المفلس تحتوي فلن يدفع دافع
الضرائب سنتا واحدا لتعويض مودع بنك
سيليكون فالي يعطي بيض ضمانا بان يستعيد
المودعون في البنك اموالهم من رسوم
التامين على الودائع وفي محاوله لاستعاده
الثقه بالنظام المصرفي الامريكي وتجنب
عمليات السحب الضخمه للودائع اتخذت
السلطات الامريكيه اجراءات من بينها ضمان
بجميع الودائع وخصوصا من بنك السيليكون
فالي المنهار كما وافق الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي الامريكي على اقراض الاموال
اللازمه لبنوك اخرى قد تحتاجها لتلبيه
طلبات السحب من عملائها هل من مستحوذ على
بنك سيليكون فالي هو الحل الامثل بالنسبه
للسلطات الامريكيه المؤسسه الاتحاديه
للتامين على الودائع التي تتولى الحراسه
القضائيه على بنك سيليكون فالي طرحت البنك
في المزاد بحثا عن مشتر او بنك اخر مستعد
لاندماج مع البنك المفلس في اقرب وقت لا
يبدو ذلك حلا يسيرا فالبنك الذي مقره
بولايه كاليفورنيا يحتل المركز السادس عشر
بين اكبر البنوك الامريكيه باصول قيمتها
209 مليارات دولار ما يقلص قائمه المشترين
المحتملين
في بريطانيا ينقشع الذعر بالاعلان عن
استحواذ بنك اتش اس بي سي على الفرع
البريطاني لبنك سيليكون فالي الامريكي تمت
الصفقه بقياده رئيس الوزراء ريشيسوناك
وباشراف بنك انجلترا ووزاره الخزانه واذا
يتربص خطر الانهيار ببنوك امريكيه تقول
حكومات اوروبيه كفرنسا والمانيا انها لا
ترى اي بوادر خطر لاصول العدوى الى بنوكها